These birria tacos
are the best thing I've put in my mouth in a while
and better than any takeout taco I've gotten.
So let's make them together.
I started off by cutting up my chuck roast into four
equal pieces,
seasoning them with salt,
and then searing them off in my Dutch oven.
Once they were done,
I pulled them out
and then chopped up some tomato, onion,
put that in my pot alongside some garlic,
tomato paste,
and my three types of chillies that I deseeded
before putting in the pot.
Put those in,
cover that with some water,
and let it simmer until the chillies were soft.
Then I transferred that over to a blender,
blended it all up until it was smooth,
and added that back to the pot with the meat,
some stocks,
some spices.
I made sure to not forget the cinnamon,
and then I put a lid on that
and let it go for three to four hours
until it was all tender.
I obviously had to taste test along the way
cause it smelled so good.
Once my meat was fall apart tender,
I shredded it all up
and then cut up some onion and cilantro,
and then it was time to assemble.
I grab my corn tortillas,
dip them in that consomme,
put them in the pan with some Oaxaca cheese,
but you can also use mozzarella,
that shredded beef,
some onion and cilantro,
and once they were ready to eat,
I dip them in that
consume, and. Oh,
my gosh, guys,
this was so good.